en directo a hoy vamos a quito este
miércoles comenzaron los diálogos entre
el gobierno de guillermo lasso y los
indígenas que lideraron las protestas
después de 18 días de movilizaciones en
contra del incremento del costo de vida
que como veíamos ocurre en varias partes
del continente ahora las partes empiezan
las negociaciones por dos puntos los
subsidios a los combustibles y la
moratoria de deudas para hablar del tema
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
ecuador gustavo ortega gustavo buenas
noches para usted cuéntenos qué ocurrió
en la primera jornada de los diálogos
para ti declara efectivamente el día de
hoy se ha iniciado finalmente lo que ha
llamado las mesas de palo de las mesas
de diálogo y la firma de un acta de paz
y luego de haber sufrido este país 1810
de paralización que sucedió al día de
hoy bueno se inició unas primeras meses
el diálogo el cual se fija la forma de
dialogar y presentar distintas en mesas
temáticas en principio el día de hoy se
ha establecido la forma de exposición y
el tiempo de exposición de los distintos
participantes y quiénes serán los
participantes el día de hoy pero también
se realizó en medio de acusaciones por
medio de parte y parte las
organizaciones indígenas ha dicho que el
diálogo está en riesgo sobre todo luego
de las declaraciones del presidente de
la república a quien señala que las
movilizaciones en este país han sido
financiadas por parte de dinero del
narcotráfico reacción que ha tenido la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador y han pedido que el
presidente de república presente pruebas
o se disculpe públicamente al señalarlos
de estar relacionado con el narcotráfico
han dicho incluso
las movilizaciones en este país
estuvieron apoyadas por el voluntariado
y la solidaridad de los ecuatorianos que
apoyaban así las movilizaciones pero qué
pasó bueno se inicia las movilizaciones
se establecen algunos temas a tratar y
básicamente se fijas cuáles serán las
distintas mesas temáticas desarrolladas
marx aclara bueno y teniendo en cuenta
la tensión con la que comenzaron las
conversaciones como usted nos lo explica
cuéntenos que se espera que pase en
estas negociaciones
pero en principio ya se ha fijado que
los primeros dos puntos a tratar serán
lo que tú ha dicho inicialmente la
focalización de los subsidios de los
combustibles ha sido la principal
demanda por parte de las organizaciones
indígenas se está tratando por parte de
los ministerios involucrados y las
organizaciones indígenas así como
beneficiar a los sectores productivos al
sector transporte al sector de
transporte de alimentos igual forma
también la moratoria de la condonación
de deudas para que los organizaciones
indígenas puedan pagar así las deudas
adquiridas durante el periodo de la
pandemia pero también se estarán
debatiendo en principio hasta esta
semana hasta el día 15 de julio y
posteriormente configurar para seguir
desarrollando otros temas relacionados
también a temas de seguridad
flexibilización laboral y también la
protección de zonas protegidas libres de
minería y petróleo me declara seguiremos
atentos a qué pasa con estos diálogos
gustavo gracias por el reporte y
nosotros tenemos más información aquí en
directo américa